in a year with four different
blockbuster spy films the great
granddaddy of them all is back and it's
bringing absolutely nothing new to the
table Spectre coming off the franchise
high of Casino Royale whatever Quantum
of Solace was and Skyfall Sam Mendes and
Daniel Craig returned with one of the
best opening scenes in Bond history
followed by three minutes of tentacle
board
followed by not much else knowing it was
much more fun in India uh hello guys did
you mute the video or something
I think somebody broke through the
volume and speak speak say something
does anyone challenge finally prepare
for bond by the numbers as you check all
the old tropes off the list like the car
gadgets catchphrases vodka martini
shaken ones to it
and underdeveloped female sex objects as
daniel craig sleep walks through a
performance where it's clear he'd rather
slash his wrists than do it again oh
poor guy had to pretend to be James Bond
for millions of dollars suck it up and
drink your martini experience a Roger
Moore era Bond film
if Roger Moore was a mopey dick trying
to get fired from his own movie that
tries to balance the playful tone of the
60s doesn't time fly
with the gritty version of bond they've
spent three movies establishing before
the splatted did you kill him
I didn't have to he didn't talk man
these things do not go well together
but bond is a franchise that's only as
good as its villains which is why this
one is so thoroughly average as they
waste the extremely talented Dave
Bautista the awesome bad guy from
Sherlock and two-time Academy Award
winner Christoph Waltz who in a surprise
twist is playing classic Bond villain
Ernst Blofeld a reveal that younger
viewers probably didn't get and older
viewers totally predicted because it
makes sense that a movie called Spectre
would have the guy who runs Spectre in
it did we learn nothing from into
darkness all are missing is that mumbo
jumbo but super blood what is it smart
blood using the small plant the smart
blood program is obviously still in its
developmental phase oh come on man
really suit up for a shoestring plot
about a generic surveillance MacGuffin
that actually expects you to remember
Quantum of Solace full of action
sequences that feel like playing
Goldeneye 64 on agent difficulty
and a bunch of crab you never wanted to
see in a Bond movie like briefings
ladies and gentlemen it's time for the
security services of the world to unite
board meetings live one of his duties
outstanding lectures about drones and
all the drones bugs cameras transcript
all the surveillance in the world can
tell you what to do next
Ledger's about meteors the cotton Hoff
the oldest and human possession therapy
you consider your employment to be
psychologically stressful sometimes
waiting for an uber blue and a finale so
lazy
there are literally arrows pointing
James Bond to the end of the movie guys
how do you make James Bond versus the
Illuminati boring so if you see only one
movie this year about a hero who belongs
in a different era
battling a sleeper cell inside his own
organization with their own tentacle
logo against a former friend that was
presumed dead in the snow you should
probably just rewatch the Winter Soldier
it's way better anyway starring bored
James bored Sean Connery Roger bore
George lazy V Pierce Brosnan Timothy
Dalton blows felled Judy Dench frowning
Ralphie in an S popular on tumblr silent
but deadly and BuzzFeed dull finger
if you though that shower scene in
Skyfall was weird wait in DC Bond
porca Widow on the day of her husband's
funeral after breaking into her house
yeah that she's totally not into that
that's creepy
Dean by James Bond standards yeah be
sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers I never made a deal with Kaji
Club I do a lot of push-ups and drink
plenty of juice I don't use contractions
blue strong enough for a man but pH
balanced for a woman I put the laughter
in slaughter that's no moon that's your
mama